the sheer scale of Destruction is hard
to comprehend
a scar of mud and Rubble Mark where the
wall of water and the remnants of
people's lives smashed through
neighborhoods and into the sea
much of the Eastern Libyan city of
derina now resembles a war zone
helicopter teams search for bodies
washed up on the shore sniffer dog units
pick through the rubble
dead are wrapped in body bags before
being pulled from the crumbled
destruction of homes
they are around 14 or 15 families that
were Swept Away anyone who was in the
valley disappeared nine other people who
lived directly on the coast are gone may
they rest in peace the sea destroyed the
Cornish we woke up to a catastrophe we
woke up and we couldn't find anyone may
God have mercy on their souls
Turner's mayor says between 18 to 20 000
people may have been killed in the
tsunami-like flooding that hit this
region earlier this week
many are being buried in Mass Graves
the completely collapsed areas estimated
at 900 000 square meters the destruction
of five bridges in this Valley resulted
in the separation of the city's East
from its West the affected area with
severe damage is estimated at 3 million
square meters the situation in this city
is more than catastrophic
the UN has warned about the threat of
disease and says Libya's political
instability is partly to blame for the
scale of the catastrophe we have tried
to help them but but since the
security situation in the country is so
difficult it's difficult to go there and
improve the situation International
humanitarian assistance including field
hospitals medicine tents and food is
being flown into the nearest large
enough airport in Benghazi 350
kilometers away
donation centers have been set up across
Libya despite the years of instability
and disunity in a country with two rival
political administrations people are
coming together to help
we heeded the call for help this is our
duty and God bless the young volunteers
who came through we provided full Food
Supplies we came with five cars people
in Benghazi donated items now we are
delivering medicine in the hospital full
Food Supplies blankets I encourage
everyone to take part even though the
roads are closed and difficult to reach
after clearing a navigational Corridor
the local Maritime authorities say
preparations are being made as quickly
as possible for ships carrying relief
supplies to enter donor's port
Charles Stratford Al Jazeera
well satellite images give us a sense of
just how much was lost in the flooding
have a look this was derna on September
the 2nd a city of about 80 000 people
there are four Bridges there that cross
the wadidona river including a main one
there along the waterfront on Wednesday
the city looked like this
the river which is dry for most of the
Year overflowed and destroyed an entire
section of the city both the bridges and
the buildings and silt has also spread
all across Turner